>> You can underline what's
covering the polar bear.
Mm-hmm, you're right.
>> At Forest Lake Elementary
School, technology is
at the core of the
learning process.
>> Do you wanna use the pointer
and make it go up
a little bit more?
>> I'm creating a battle on
the game code Medieval Two,
and we have to research what
kind of people they had there,
and like the terrain
of the land and stuff.
>> In history class,
Ian uses game software
to recreate Revolutionary War
battles and a Blackboard account
to make daily journal entries.
Technology also provides
a window
on the classroom for parents.
By accessing her son's
Blackboard account at home,
Ian's mom can see what he's
doing in class every day.
She can also check on
upcoming assignments,
and his teachers'
recommendations
for extra credit work.
>> Right now I'm on my son
Ian's Blackboard account.
He's my fourth grader.
He likes me to read what
he's written sometimes,
and this is just an example.
It's a little, I guess, blog.
And he's just talking about
all the different things
that they did today with
their particular group.
"We are at peace with the
French and the Swedish,
and the Dutch want to be allies
with us, but we haven't decided
if we want to be
allies with them yet."
So that's actually other
groups in their class,
and he's just kind
of writing down,
"One of our most important
seas is off the Gulf of Mexico.
We need to transport
goods from Florida."
It's amazing, you can see
the facts that are woven in,
just from him writing
this journal.
So I love to get on and
read that kind of thing.
And then also, here's
an example.
Study Island is a really fun
place that they can study
for their different
reading and grammar skills.
You'll see here, it says,
"Online Learning, Extra Practice
and Early Finishers," so this
is a place where their teacher,
Mr. Durden, has placed
several links.
Also, if he forgets
an assignment,
he can go on Blackboard
and find out what it is,
instead of having to bother
the teacher or call a friend.
He can just go right
online and find it out.
>> Blackboard accounts
cost just two dollars
and fifty cents per
student for the year.
They're paid for by the school
district, which also contracted
with a local web team to
design a special portal just
for parents.
>> It's pretty easy.
You can sign into the account
and you can keep up
with their grades.
And it's a nice way
to keep track
of how your children are
doing, and not let it get away
from you, where you don't find
out till a week before the
nine weeks ends, "Oh no,
they're making a C
or a D or whatever."
So, and they actually email me
any time a new grade comes up,
so I can go on there.
I probably go on there, maybe
three or four times a week.
Maybe more than I should, but
it makes it very easy to be able
to see how your children
are doing.
>> For more information
on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org